So today,
uh,
as you can see on the syllabus,
the lecture is titled Organizing a war.
And on this past Thursday I talked about the opening phases of what basically
is,
I described,
it is a civil war.
I talked about opening hostilities including Lexington and Concord.
And I showed how even with these opening hostilities still we could see how long
it took before independence was actually declared.
Basically launching a civil war was not an easy decision or for a time at least
even a logical one,
nor was organizing and fighting a civil war easy,
particularly for 13 colonies that were not used to acting in unison.
And as we saw a really early on in the course,
the colonies tended to come together for purposes of self defense when
necessary.
And then when no longer necessary,
they were definitely not joined together in joint cause past that point.
So the colonies and then states did not naturally fall into a union of some kind
unless there was danger at hand and often only when danger was at hand.
Well today what we're going to be looking at is some of the challenges facing
these,
well now they're stays now that you've declared independence 13 states when they
came together in the opening phases of this civil war for their mutual defense
and as we're going to see during the lecture on the one hand,
given that togetherness was not really their natural state of being,
they did manage to accomplish quite a bit convened in the continental Congress.
But on the other hand,
the process of organizing award did not end up being a very efficient business
in many ways and that's really going to be the main subject of what I'm going to
talk about today and the experience of trying to accomplish things with only a
week continental congress acting as the central organizational body actually
ended up convincing some people down the road that I stronger government then
that one was going to be necessary when people were trying to figure out a more
permanent form of government for these newly independent states.
So one of the things I'll be showing and talking about by the end of the lecture
is the ways in which real life experiences were convincing.
Some people are teaching some people even a better word,
um,
lessons about governance in these new states and about what they thought worked
and what they thought didn't.
There was never great uniform agreement,
but you'll see why some people emerged from the revolutionary war effort
thinking that something stronger and more centralized with necessary.
Okay,
so now let's turn to the continental Congress and how they organized a war.
Now,
the effort really began in earnest in May of 1775 when the second continental
congress was first sitting just after Lexington and Concord because it was in
May of 1775 that the continental congress took direction of colonial military
resistance to the British by creating the continental army.
Now,
I ended Thursday's lecture with a quote by John Adams from a letter that he
wrote to Abigail when which he was summing up some of the challenges facing
congress.
I'll repeat it here because it's going to outline some of the things that we
will be talking about in today's lecture.
And what Adams wrote was when 50 or 60 men have a constitution to form for a
great empire,
at the same time they have a country of 1500 miles extent to fortify millions to
arm and train a naval power to begin an extensive commerce to regulate numerous
tribes of Indians to negotiate with a Standing Army of 27,000 men to raise pay,
visual and officer,
I shall really pity those 50 or 60 men.
Okay,
so that's Adam's writing to Abigail,
like basically saying,
oh my God,
this is what we have in front of us.
This will not be easy.
And you can see in that quote the scope of the task that really did lie before
the continental Congress figuring out how to govern the 13 states,
worrying about issues having to do with commerce,
negotiating with native Americans and of course in war time,
most central of all given military hostilities that we're right in hand creating
and supplying an army.
And it's that latter task that I'm going to focus on at the moment.
I'm going to be looking at how the continental Congress created and supplied the
continental army because in a lot of ways,
when you look at all of the complications and controversies surrounding the
creation of the continental army,
you get a great case study of many of the problems that were at the heart of any
effort at unity between the colonies and then the states.
And not surprisingly,
it's we're going to see down the road in this chorus when we talk more about the
1718 many of these problems certainly did persist as problems,
not only through the revolution,
but through the 1780s through the nation's first decades and in some cases long
thereafter.
So in a sense,
you can look at the creation of the continental army as a kind of case study and
some of the problems involved with creating an American Union.
Now,
given what I've just said about problems inherent creating a union,
it's not surprising that one of the first problems to present itself as far as
the continental army is concerned was regionalism.
I'm going to talk in a moment about localism,
but for now and then talk about regionalism.
Um,
you might think that in a moment of crisis,
regionalism might entirely fall by the wayside.
And I suppose in some ways it did,
but definitely not completely.
And as I'm going to talk about it in a moment,
you can see this,
particularly when you talk about the issue of who's going to command the
continental army.
Um,
I remember when I was first working on my book,
which is about politics and the 1790s.
And I thought without looking into it very much that what I was going to find
when I started looking at letters from the period was that there'd be this
little honeymoon nationalism moment where everyone thought,
you know,
well,
we just created a constitution and we're not sure about if it,
let's hang in there and be national together.
Let's not really focus on regionalism for just a little while.
And then maybe there'd be this little honeymoon moment and then that might sort
of wane.
And then people would get more back into their entrenched sort of regional
outlooks.
And what I found is that no,
there wasn't a honeymoon nationalism.
It,
it just,
it never happened that even as soon as that the national government is launched
in the 1790s,
even when people have decided to commit,
at least for the present to this new constitution,
they were still thinking about,
Whoa,
southerners.
I don't know if,
what trust the northerners,
northerners,
I don't know if I trust the southerners.
I remember finding a letter,
um,
from one southern to another southerner from like the first year or two that the
government was in existence and the one southerner says to the other,
um,
you know,
I think we should try as hard as we can to get as many young men in clerkships
in this new government as possible because then they're going to gradually be
promoted into higher offices and sooner or later,
southern men will be in control of most of the national offices,
which is much better than being governed by a bunch of arrogant northerners.
Okay.
This is like the government hasn't even been in existence yet for two years and
already people are like,
ah,
I don't know about that other,
those northerners.
So it doesn't,
it waxes and wanes.
It doesn't go away.
Um,
and so it's not surprising given that that it pops up right at the outset of the
whole revolutionary enterprise,
particularly when people were thinking about a commander in chief of the
continental army.
Now obviously in and of itself,
it's an important decision you where you want the right man for that job.
But it was complicated by regional concerns.
Basically many new Englanders felt that since during this early period of the
war,
most of the military action was happening in New England.
Basically all the hostilities we've been talking about,
much of it certainly is going on in New England,
that a new Englander would be the logical choice to lead the army.
And some people even had the sneaking suspicion that maybe new Englanders would
we be willing to fight under anybody else?
Um,
people thought about the way that the new England militia operated as units.
one of the striking things about the new England militia was that they actually
elected their officers,
right.
It wasn't like someone was sort of enforced upon them as an officer.
Militia units elected their own officers.
So given that the fat was given,
that kind of military culture,
having a southerner thrust upon them might not be welcomed with open arms by New
England troops on a much more minor note.
Complicating matters was that not only did some people think I know England or
made the most sense,
but also John Hancock and some of his friends actually thought that he was the
guy who should be commander in chief.
They had pretty much already decided John Hancock,
he's the man.
Just a matter of time before he gets nominated and made commander in chief of
the army.
So for a variety of reasons,
some people thought maybe a southerner would not work as commander in chief.
But on the other hand,
there were other people who felt just the opposite who actually thought that
because a lot of what had been happening so far had been going on in New England
and that new Englanders had been doing a lot of the fighting,
all the more reason to promote unity among the colonies by finding someone who
wasn't a new Englander,
by fighting a southerner to be commander in chief and suggested this was a joint
continental effort and not some New England war.
And this kind of logic,
this kind of wondering about how do you balance out positions,
officerships cabinet offices,
diplomatic posts.
This goes on and on and on throughout this period that people are always very
concerned whether you're talking about military positions or whether you're
talking about civil positions.
Um,
even presidents had the same problem.
Washington certainly has it throughout the war as commander in chief was this
constant concern about trying to balance things out regionally.
Not just,
oh,
because it would seem fair,
but actually if you think about the fact that a union,
whether you're talking about the 1770s the seventies eighties or the 1790s if
you think about the fact that whatever he kind of union you have,
it's pretty weak if you actually don't think about things like balancing between
regions and in different positions of responsibility and authority.
The fear was that may parts of the union that didn't feel included and didn't
feel represented.
My actually just pull out of the union and throughout this period actually later
than one would think that was a constant threat that the sections of the of the
union would threaten to pull out because they felt that they weren't really
being included as important members sort of again and again at key moments.
There's a little sort of threat of succession that raises its head and then is
sort of shoved back down until finally it raises its head and it's not shoved
back down.
But certainly that was a logical fear.
And so wondering about balance was a problem for anyone who is in any position
of authority or command throughout this period.
So in the case of the army commander in chief,
obviously this is a big and typical kind of a decision.
So some favor Handcock others favored of Virginia named George Washington.
Um,
we've already seen Washington did have military experience as an officer
fighting during the French and Indian war.
He made a few choices that perhaps were not the best.
However,
he was someone who did have extensive military experience fighting alongside or
as part of the British army.
He also was a person,
he really did kind of have a commanding presence.
He was someone who seemed like he ought to be a military leader.
Um,
couple,
gosh,
it's probably couple of years ago.
Um,
I went,
I was giving a talk at,
at Mount Vernon and they have a new,
um,
like a sort of museum education center at Mount Vernon,
which is actually really big,
really impressive.
Um,
and one of the things that they did was they created three life scale,
exact models of George Washington,
that sort of key moments.
So you have Washington as a surveyor,
Washington during the revolution,
Washington taking the oath of office as president and they,
I mean,
like literally like measured its skull and did whatever they had to do to make
it like exact George Washington.
So,
you know,
I'm the historian,
I'm giving the talk.
I'm like,
Oh,
a little bit of time for the talk.
I'll go wander around the visitor center and I see,
you know,
there's Washington,
a surveyor,
Huh.
Wow.
Who would've thought I would've seen there is,
it's kind of realistic looking and then I wander into the revolution room and
okay,
it's for however long I've been studying this period.
You see a bazillion times people will say the man was an impressive figure on a
horse.
Like everyone finds a way of saying that he was an impressive figure on the
horse up on that white horse.
What a man,
you know,
one way or another.
Everyone sort of,
ah,
and I thought,
yeah,
okay.
I know this impressive,
whereas a finger on the heart.
So I walk into this room,
there's Washington on the horse,
and without even thinking,
I said,
wow,
he's an impressive figure.
I was like,
okay,
it must be true.
I couldn't help myself,
like really impressive.
So he looked like someone who ought to be in command.
Um,
another useful thing about George Washington,
and you'll see it's,
it's a little complicated.
Um,
but he didn't seem ambitious,
but one of the,
one of the overriding assumptions in politics at this time is if you really are
openly power hungry,
if you really are very openly ambitious,
you're the exact person who should not be given power.
Particularly if you're looking at a republic or a confederation or some kind of
a form of government that's weak or shaky or knew.
The thought is if you get a power hungry person and you give that person power,
they're very likely to become a tyrant or a desperate and then basically seize
control of the government.
And then poof,
everything is gone.
And now you just have a despotism.
So you don't want to give ambitious people power.
And George Washington though he did have any number of talents and skills and he
though he was certainly ambitious,
as you'll see in a moment.
He wasn't the kind of guy who seemed to be pulling for power.
He wasn't sort of guy who was campaigning for himself.
He wasn't the sort of guy who sort of pushing himself into situations.
He really had kind of a modest demeanor in,
in how he presented himself when up for some kind of an office.
And a great example of that is what happens when he shows up to the continental
congress and he's been named a delegate to the continental congress and he shows
up and he shows up in his military uniform.
Okay,
he's the only guy in a military uniform,
right?
He shows up like,
hi,
I'm George Washington guy in a uniform,
big George think command picture.
You know,
he's not saying anything,
he's not campaigning,
but he's definitely putting the idea out there.
Like,
I'm a military guy and you're looking for one right now,
and here I am in my uniform waiting for you to know how to say it was a,
a sort of skillful play on his part to just sort of plant the subliminal message
in everyone's mind.
So surely he wanted to be commander in chief and it ends up being Adams who
nominates Washington for the position of commander in chief,
which really,
really irked John Hancock,
who thought that as a Massachusetts man,
when Adam starts talking that obviously Adams must be talking about him.
So before Adam says,
Washington's names that are Hancock's like,
ha,
yes,
indeed.
That's me.
I deserve this post.
And Adams actually later recall to this,
he says he stood up to nominate Washington.
He says that Washington,
who was sitting near the door of the room,
quote,
as soon as he heard me allude to him from his usual modesty,
darted into the library room.
Okay.
So Adam says up and says,
I want to talk about commander in chief.
And Washington goes boohoo out of the room.
Not that anyone will notice.
It's like,
no,
I don't want to be in the room.
So Adams presents his reasons as to why he thinks this particular unnamed person
would be good for the post of commander in chief Handcock thinks clearly that
Adams has talking about him.
Adam says,
Mr. Hancock,
who was our president,
he's presiding over the continental congress,
heard me with visible pleasure until I came to describe Washington for the
commander.
I never remarked a more sudden and striking change of countenance,
mortification and resentment were expressed as forcibly as his face could
exhibit them.
Okay.
That's a really sort of Nice little moment there.
Hancock was not pleased.
However,
Washington was appointed commander in chief of the continental army,
June 15th,
1775.
Now,
he may have been a good person for this job.
This is not to say he didn't have regional prejudices of his own.
Um,
and I think earlier in the course,
of course I quoted him about new Englanders.
Did I do that?
Yeah.
Okay.
I thought so.
Um,
that's,
that quote actually comes from this moment in the course.
That quote comes from in Washington first goes up to New England to take his
position as commander in chief and meet this New England army that has been made
commander of,
and his response to looking at the army is what I quoted before.
New Englanders are an exceeding dirty and nasty people.
Okay.
That's George Washington,
father of our country,
of the continental army on the army that he is just inherited.
So he's not exactly thrilled.
He doesn't eat that isn't necessarily commanded men like this before.
And he's also a little,
um,
I didn't know what the right word is.
Befuddled.
I'm struck by the mood or the way in which these troops conduct themselves.
Um,
as I mentioned before,
you know,
New England,
it's like a town meeting government kind of a place and they're electing their
officers and their military units to Washington.
This,
he just cook.
This did not make sense electing an officer.
Like what kind of authority does an elected officer have?
He didn't like the idea was pretty foreign as far as military thinking goes to
Washington.
And he wasn't entirely sure that he could actually tell the officer's apart from
the common soldiers,
which is probably true if they're electing people from their midst.
So Washington definitely saw new Englanders as unfamiliar to say the least when
he took command of the army.
Again,
regionalism,
regionalism was also apparent in just the mere appearance of the soldiers.
They came from ultimately different parts of the confederation.
Um,
some of the more striking looking people came from the frontier frontier
riflemen from Virginia and I think Pennsylvania as well.
Um,
these were guys who are dressed in hunting shirts.
They didn't have formal uniforms,
they didn't carry muskets,
but instead they carried rifles which are assumed to be sharp shooting,
sharper shooting,
I guess than a musket was.
Um,
some of them carried Tomahawks and they were very proud of their shooting
skills.
They were kind of a wild bunch.
Um,
there's a,
um,
rather eccentric American general who will come up again in the course.
His name is Charles Lee.
Um,
and he always referred to the riflemen quote as that damned riff Raff.
He just thought they were these wild and crazy guys from add on the frontier
armed with rifles.
So,
and Lee,
I should note,
I'll mention Lee again later.
Um,
Lee,
he's,
everyone describes him as eccentric,
even lead,
describes himself as eccentric,
but maybe one of the more eccentric things about Charles Lee was that he had a
pack of dogs that he loved and that followed him everywhere he went.
I mean,
everywhere you went.
if he went into a ladies parlour,
he had six dogs,
you know,
if he went into a lady's private chamber,
apparently he had six dogs.
So it was not particularly popular with the female kind.
Um,
and he's,
uh,
he's an eccentric individual for a variety of reasons and he ends up having a
bad,
bad moment during the revolution,
which we'll come to.
But,
um,
anyway,
so Charles,
if Charles leads calling people that Damn River that actually says something.
So anyway,
the riflemen were kind of a wild crew.
They saw themselves as the elite of the army because of their shooting skills.
Um,
they actually spent some time sort of taking pot shots at British officers on
the line until the British officers realized that there were these kinds of
crazy rifle mid taking shots at them and it would be good not to be out in the
open anymore.
Um,
they also just like shooting off their guns for fun.
Ammunition supplies were very low and this was not a good idea.
I'll come back to this in a minute,
but they were a little bit wild.
Um,
and they did not necessarily like to be disciplined.
So for example,
in one instance there was one Virginia rifleman who was arrested for not
listening to orders and other riflemen stormed the jail and freed him.
Okay,
wait,
this is not intense military discipline taking place here at this time.
And of course on the other hand,
you couldn't give all kinds of privileges to the riflemen because then all the
other troops would say,
well,
why are those guys getting treated special?
You know,
like they're better than us.
So,
so the army's kind of clinical Hama ration of different kinds of people,
different places,
even different uniforms that just different behavior.
So you can see just in the matter of managing an army,
regionalism can add complications and problems.
It's also a problem in a slightly different form,
and I'm going to call it localism cause I mean it in a slightly different way
than I mean regionalism.
And,
and what I mean by local ism is people often tended to think of their own
locality first and foremost rather than necessarily than of the good of the
entire American cause.
So people thought about wherever they were from first and foremost and along
similar lines,
they were distrustful about surrendering local authority to any kind of a
centralized authority.
Now in the continental army,
obviously this is going to make it extremely complicated to gather together one
United armed force.
Every state had its own militia.
State legislatures want it to stay in control of their own militias.
Some of these militias stayed separate from the continental army.
They states certainly didn't want to surrender control of their own military
defense to some kind of central organization that wouldn't necessarily put their
interests first.
So the very idea of combining some of these militias into one big United one in
a sense,
the continental army with controversial and at the start of the war,
in many ways the army was kind of a collection of separate little military
delegations,
just like the continental congress and some ways was a collection of separate,
separate little state delegations.
This same fear about surrendering local control and about protecting local
interests made it extremely difficult for the continental congress to organize
and orchestrate the war effort.
Because as a body,
the continental congress had virtually no power of enforcement.
It could advise the states,
it could ask them for things,
it could make recommendations,
it could not order a state to do something and then enforce that order.
It had no real power of enforcement.
And this came to be a particularly big problem when it came to supplying the
army.
Given that the states didn't rush forward to supply soldiers from other states,
supplying the continental army in any kind of a reliable way,
sometimes was virtually impossible.
So whatever the congress tried to do in the way of making requests,
requests,
or making recommendations about supplies,
like,
you know,
we recommend that each state provide x pounds of food and x number of blankets
for the use of the continental army.
You just absolutely couldn't tell on a,
on the reality level what would happen as a result of that kind of an order.
And this was a big problem because there was an enormous supply shortage in the
continental army as well as in the local militias.
The scale of supplies required by this army was huge.
So for example,
during three months,
December of 1777 and January and February of 1778 so during the three month
period,
the army eight more than 2 million pounds of beef,
2 million pounds of flour and their horses,
eight 2 million tons of Hay.
Okay?
That's a lot of supplies,
particularly if you have no really organized way to get it.
And American started the war deficient in almost every necessity.
Guns,
ammunition,
Flint,
artillery,
steel for bayonets,
clothing,
tents,
blankets.
The solution obviously would be for the continental Congress to organize some
kind of a central supply system,
which they tried to do.
But again,
without being able to enforce things,
that was not a very effective way to proceed.
This wasn't all congress' fault.
Congress wasn't very good at the implementation.
The actual shortage of supplies,
ironically enough in part,
was caused by the fact that British imports,
we're no longer being taken right in the colonies and the states,
so that the states have been so busy like saying,
no,
we do not want those evil British imported goods.
Now they're like,
oh,
we kind of might have been able to use some of that stuff now that we're
actually fighting the British.
Um,
so in time they,
when the,
the states began to encourage other countries to bring imported goods,
this became a little bit less extreme.
But that is sort of a weird,
ironic problem that arose when the war broke out.
In the meantime,
there were some American soldiers fighting with spears,
fighting with Tomahawks.
Benjamin Franklin apparently thought that bows and arrows might be a really good
idea.
Um,
and he was serious and he calculated,
okay,
it's a calculating guy.
You remember?
He's the guy who backed away from George Whitefield to see how far,
okay,
so he's calculating again,
and he calculated this time that you could,
single soldier could shoot off four arrows in the time that it took him to load
and fire his gun so that maybe it's even a great idea to have the soldiers
fighting with bows and arrows that didn't necessarily go very far,
but he was thinking about it
as long as the states were so wary about surrendering control to Congress
supplies really where a seemingly insurmountable problem,
and there are actually stories of Washington's aids literally going farmhouse to
farmhouse and knocking on doors to ask people for blankets and supplies and
wagons and whatever they could get.
I mean,
literally the army sometimes was reduced to that level.
Given that kind of problem.
It makes sense that the experience of fighting the war convinced many people
that there did need to be something stronger,
something more centralized at the center of whatever kind of confederation was
forming.
Um,
and particularly people who were at military headquarters with Washington,
which includes Alexander Hamilton since they were the guys who were seeing
problems with supplies and how Congress couldn't seem to do anything forcefully
and efficiently.
It's not surprising that many of those people ended up being really strong
nationalists who really wanted a stronger centralized government,
Hamilton frustrated at headquarters.
Just seeing what he saw as this sort of amazing,
potentially deadly inefficiency of the continental Congress really early in the
war.
He's already coming forward and saying we need a stronger centralized power.
We need a stronger centralized power even before anyone is really tough thinking
about,
hmm,
what kind of government comes later,
you know,
how has and sort of already out there pounding away.
And it's partly based on his real life experience of what it's like to try and
be governed by the continental army while being in the army during a time of
war.
So this is basically an interesting and important point.
It'll come up again towards the end of the course,
but basically they were real life experiences behind people's theoretical ideas
about what kind of government would be desirable for the new American nation.
When we get to the part of the course where we're talking about,
um,
the constitution and different ideas and sort of what led up to it and why
people thought one thing or thought another thing.
Some of those ideas are not sort of high falutin sort of detached thoughts about
federalism,
but they're actually based on real life experiences and real lessons and people
looking at what has been happening and then drawing conclusions and coming to
different conclusions,
but still drawing conclusions based on what they've just experienced about what
should be happening next.
Okay.
So basically centralized coordination,
scary thing for the states.
Not good news for organizing a continental army.
Neither was the complete lack of a precedent for what the congress was doing in
organizing this war.
If you think about Great Britain,
think about all of the sophisticated administrative machinery that they would
have had there for conducting a war.
And then think about the American states that have really nothing in place.
They're really starting from scratch.
And the people in Congress who are responsible for organizing the army,
we're not men with vast military experience of the roughly 65 congressmen that
were in attendance in 1775 and 1776 only five had served with the British during
the French and Indian war.
Only one of these five had real experience in supplies.
And that experience tainted back to 1759 none really had experience with medical
matters in a time of war.
Only two had any medical training and they were not on the medical committee.
So bureaucracy,
even at an early point,
let's take the two medical guys and put them on the Green Committee.
I know.
So basically you have a bunch of people here who are trying to figure out from
scratch how to create a coordinated army effort.
By 1778,
Congress began to try to improve its administrative structure and it did begin
to create boards of war and boards of Admiralty.
Um,
but even once they started to have an organized administrative force,
habits of individual congressmen were unpredictable.
There wasn't even a way to enforce attendance to the continental Congress.
And again,
sometimes continental congressmen thought that what was happening at home
demanded their attention more than whatever was going on with the continental
congress.
So they just didn't show up to the point that in April of 1778,
Congress actually circulated a written statement that was titled Engagement of
members to meet punctually.
Okay.
The Gut,
they actually published a little reminder saying,
uh,
we really need you guys to come to the congress.
I mean,
we're kind of having a war and bad things are happening.
We really,
we'd like you to be here so you can actually do things.
Even just attendance sometimes could be a problem.
And that really didn't accomplish very much.
As one historian wrote,
Congress was too inefficient to correct its own inefficiency.
That's not good.
Okay.
So obviously things are,
are somewhat unpredictable.
Occasionally random and this made congressional control and organization a
problem throughout the war
and it wasn't just congressmen who are inexperienced with this kind of issue and
we're having problems with the whole question of supplies.
Supply issues were complicated by the behavior of soldiers,
many of whom for the most part had not ever been soldiers before.
So they're also not following any precedent.
It's not like they're a trained military force.
And many of them were often far more interested in protecting their locality
than in anything else and their behavior in battles when far from home with
sometimes not ideal.
Also because they were not always sure what they were doing.
They were not very careful with the supplies that they were given.
Like the riflemen,
they fired off their guns for fun.
Um,
they sold,
sometimes they're closing ammunition if they needed cash.
Um,
when they were beating a hasty retreat,
they tended to just throw anything that was heavy and getting in their way on
the ground as they ran one soldier who returned to a place where the army,
the continental army had just retreated,
said the ground was literally covered with arms,
knapsacks staves,
coats,
hats,
and old oil flask.
I mean,
these people,
they just dropped things and ran and left them on the field.
So there's,
there's no precedent in so many levels for what we're talking about here.
There was no precedent for an organized continental army.
There was no precedent for an organized continental army administration.
So troops had to learn how to behave like an army while already fighting a war,
which leads to another problem at the start of the war.
And that is the problem of what certainly one or two European visitors saw as
the attitude of the American troops.
In part,
as I just suggested,
many soldiers were just ignorant about military operations,
about how an army was supposed to be organized.
They hadn't been soldiers.
They didn't know how an army was supposed to work.
They had to be trained from scratch.
Now,
Baron von Steuben was a foreign volunteer that arrived in the states in 1777.
Specifically,
he was given the task of training the continental army.
He was someone who had experience with European armies.
He was given the task of training the American troops,
um,
and didn't speak a lot of English when he first came here.
He actually was much better in French and German.
And so according to people at the time when he was training the troops,
he,
Kristin three different languages at the same time,
English,
French,
German,
and I guess he cursed a lot.
I think he was probably a little surprised by what the troops could not do.
Um,
supposedly a store had been and others who are trying to train the troops
discovered among other things that,
um,
it was very hard to teach them people to March because they didn't always
consistently no left foot and right foot.
Right.
If that's something you hadn't thought about before,
I suppose you're not thinking about it as you're walking.
So,
and I'm such a city slicker here that I don't know the difference.
And I always,
every,
every year when I say was like count on someone in the class,
you think one of you will know to sort of interpret this for me?
Um,
supposedly or at least anecdotally.
one of the things that they did to train these troops was they tied.
Hey,
on one foot and Straw on the other foot.
I said,
hey foot straw foot,
hey foot,
Straw foot.
And that was the way that people were initially taught.
Demarche.
Now of course city slicker me.
What is the difference between Hay and Straw?
I would be bad.
I would be even worse.
I would be not knowing how to march in the continental army cause I wouldn't
know which was my hey foot.
Does anybody here know the difference between Hay and Straw?
Oh yes.
It's pretty much just like the stem of the week.
It's all
grass and I'll be like,
we're animals in it.
Okay.
So Straw is the,
just the stem of the wheat and Hay.
Hey has actual food mixed in?
Thank you very much.
I know there had to be someone who knows something about a farm.
I greatly appreciate that.
Okay,
I'm writing it down for next time.
We're talking about this.
Okay.
I have it written down now.
I might,
my fact for the day that I learned.
Thank you very much.
Um,
now it's one story.
It's one of the people who looked at the continental soldiers and commented on
what he took to be a particularly American attitude.
Supposedly what story been said was in the Prussian army officers said to a
soldier,
do this and he does it,
but I am obliged to say this is the reason why you want to do that.
And then he does it.
The Americans are operating in a slightly different way from,
from what he considers a traditional European armies behavior.
Basically,
Americans didn't always respond well to orders.
They wanted to take part in decisions.
They wanted their opinions to be represented.
Obviously this kind of political sensibility could present problems if you're
trying to command men in an army.
It also created problems with terms of enlistment.
Soldiers tended to sign on for one year at a time and when the year was over,
they just often went home.
They were in the army by choice and they felt that they basically had no need to
listen to any kind of higher command telling them to stay.
We'll see you a little bit later in a future lecture.
Washington literally pleading with the man,
please don't go home.
I know you can go home.
Please don't go home.
Please stay just a little bit longer.
So for example,
at the end of 1775,
a big chunk of the army just packed up and went home.
So America essentially changed armies at the beginning of 1776 found new men and
listed them for another one year term and it was assumed that at the end of
another year the same thing would happen again.
It took a while before Congress agreed to try and regulate and linkedin terms of
enlistment.
There was a similar problem involved with social rank and military rank.
Um,
I've already mentioned very early in the course that social rank hierarchy in
the colonies was a little bit more slippery than in England.
So that while there certainly was an elite in the colonies and the states,
there was a disorder of entrenched to the manor born aristocratic class as there
would have been in England.
And the difference between a gentleman and a more common man could sometimes be
hard to tell.
Well,
Washington wanted gentlemen to serve as commanding officers.
Basically he wanted to use social rank to enforce military rank thinking that if
you respected someone as your social superior,
you'd probably respect him as your military superior as Washington put it.
The true criteria of judgment about who should be an officer when past services
do not enter into the competition is whether the candidate for office has adjust
pretension to the character of a gentlemen,
a proper sense of honor and some reputation to lose,
right?
Vsm reputation to lose,
he's going to worry about losing it.
So there's a logic for having an officer.
Now,
this may sound logical by 18th century terms is kind of logic,
but it often presented a problem because sometimes there really wasn't all that
much separating socially as far as rank is concerned,
officers from non officers and again,
think about the new Englanders promoting people from within their own.
Sometimes there wasn't really much of a social rank differentiating officers at
all.
There's one historian who argues that,
um,
one of the reason why there was dueling prevalent among some of the younger
officers and the continental army was because they were actually dueling to
prove that they could do it,
which meant that they were actually gentlemen or of the gentleman class,
which meant they were actually better than some of the men they were commanding
who were pretty much,
they're equal.
So,
so dueling was away for these young officers to sort of prove that they deserved
to be elite.
So we're talking about kind of a fuzzy line here that was not helpful for
Washington and trying to figure out how to get disciplined in order in the army.
This is certainly not something that you would have found in the British or
French army where social rank and military rank was much more defined and
established.
And it's one of the reason why Europeans came to America to fight during the
American revolution.
Some of them came because they were inspired by the cause.
Some of them came because they would not have been able to promote themselves in
the British or French army or some other army.
But in the continental army they were Europeans.
They seem sophisticated.
They seem to have experienced,
they could go to the continental army,
say that they would fight for the cause if they were given a commission as an
officer and they'd be given one.
And this was enormously demoralizing for some of the continental army officers
who are not being promoted.
They watch these people come in from other countries and be promoted above them.
Um,
Alexander Hamilton said it gave him pygmy feelings this,
this idea that these foreigners could come in because they were supposedly
better than us and then get promoted over us.
And we were just a bunch of rustic boobs and we didn't get as quickly as they
did.
So some people from foreign countries,
we're actually taking advantage of the sort of ambiguity in the states at the
time.
Okay.
So looking at the process of organizing a war,
we've seen regionalism and localism and action working against centralized
control and organization.
We've seen complications of social rack and the sort of individualism of the
troops and making it hard again to organize and command.
Um,
and overall we've seen a congress that all in all,
it doesn't have that much power really struggling to exert some kind of
centralized control over a continental war effort.
So in essence the things that were complicating unity between the colonies and
then the states are the same things logically that are going to complicate and
confuse efforts to create some kind of continental war effort.
We'll see this continuing in a different way in the seventies and eighties.
Now we've been looking at,
I want to just take a few minutes here.
We've been looking at some of the realities of the continental army.
I brought in a handout.
Um,
partly because I'm very low tech and so I didn't bring a computer,
but partly because I actually really wanted you to hold this in your hands.
Um,
and while it's being passed out,
I'll talk about what it is before you get your hands on it.
It's actually a newspaper,
a Connecticut newspaper from July eight,
1776.
It's the entire newspaper,
as you will see.
It's a little bit smaller than it would have been,
but not tremendously smaller than it would have been.
Um,
but as you'll see,
it's it,
it's called the weekly,
you know,
so it came out once a week.
Um,
it is four pages long.
I'll wait as it sort of gets passed out here.
Um,
it,
this particular one is the Connecticut current.
It was printed in Hartford.
Um,
and as I mentioned the date,
July 8th,
1776.
Um,
so as you're getting it,
you'll notice you look at the,
um,
front page and me get my coffee here.
Um,
you can see that it contains the freshest advices,
both foreign and domestic.
Okay.
News,
fresh news.
And one of the first things that you'll see on the front page and the left hand
column is persons that are being held up to public view as enemies to their
country.
Like right off the cuff,
these are probably people who may be were treating with loyalists.
They're supplying the enemy army are denouncing the glocal congress who knows
what they were doing,
but whatever they were doing,
it was bad.
And they're being publicly shamed on the front page of this newspaper.
And it suggests,
it says confession $1,
which suggest that you could step forward and confess and apologize and pay a
dollar sort of,
okay.
You know,
I won't do it again.
I can't say I've seen any concession,
but certainly many,
many issues of this paper when I was looking through them contain that column
with more people being publicly shamed.
Okay.
So,
um,
if you look at the paper,
you could see right off the cuff,
you have something being reprinted from a Pennsylvania newspaper.
Um,
it actually is a declaration that someone's ranting about the British and then
goes on to say,
you know,
why doesn't the continental Congress reward any British officer who deserves the
British army by giving him land here?
Yeah,
what a great idea.
We'll get them to dessert by promising them land and then they'll come over to
our side and you can see they have different amounts of acres that they're
proposing.
Um,
so it's like a little plan.
I can't say it goes anywhere,
but it's an interesting little plan.
Um,
you could see next if there's news from London dated March 21st.
Okay.
We're July 8th.
So there are several things in this paper that are a reminder of how slow news
traveled,
particularly from overseas back to the states and the colonies.
This is actually a debate in parliament about the death of an American general,
uh,
General Montgomery,
which moves into being a debate about the rebels.
And you can see capital letters,
rebel,
rebel rebellions sort of throughout that column.
Then we've got news from Williamsburg on the bottom there on the third column,
we've got a couple little advertisements.
For a political pamphlet and cash needed for old cloths basically.
So the printing press folk and clean off the presses.
Um,
one of the things you notice is it,
it's sort of random news,
often printed from other newspapers.
Um,
they're on the top of the second page from North Carolina.
You actually could see that North Carolina is instructing its delegates in the
continental Congress,
um,
that they should,
that they would be able to declare independence.
There's kind of a major statement boom right there,
sort of by itself.
No commentary.
Um,
you can see one thing,
actually we're running out of time,
but one of the things you will not see July eight,
1776 is the declaration of independence.
It has not gotten here yet in time to be printed and it's actually not till the
next edition on the 15th of July that you see the declaration of independence
actually get printed in this newspaper.
No commentary.
Just sort of like that little North Carolina Declaration,
just boom.
They just sort of printed,
it takes up about two columns and that's it.
Um,
this paper is typical of many and that it would start out having typically,
I suppose this,
this one hasn't mixed,
but sometimes you'd have international news and then national news and then
local news.
And then on the back you'd had that have advertisements.
And in a general way,
this paper's kind of following that trend.
Um,
let's see if there's anything else I want to point out.
You'll see on the third page we've got news from Hartford,
so it's become local by the third page.
Um,
you'll see on the third column there deserted Colonel From Colonel John Wards,
regiment one Tilson mills.
It looks like Miller.
I'm sorry,
a drummer.
He's about 30 years old,
five foot six inches high.
It has a peak to Chin and something of a guilty look.
I love that.
You'll see that throughout this column.
And the last page,
there are a couple listings about deserters people looking for deserters.
Um,
you'll see someone,
where is he?
He's on the third page.
Um,
Roger on the,
on the third column on the third page,
Roger March of Litchfield opposed and spoke against the measures of Congress.
He's probably going to be enemy to our country and the first column of the first
page in the next edition of this newspaper.
So basically I,
um,
I've handed this to you just so that you could get a sense of what a typical
newspaper would have looked like.
What you would've seen if you were in Hartford,
Connecticut on July 8th,
1776.
This would have been what was at your disposal for whatever was happening in
Connecticut for whatever was happening throughout the states for whatever was
happening overseas.
Some of that overseas news goes back to March,
but this is how people are learning about whatever is happening in that entire
war effort.
It's haphazard.
It's kind of random.
It's slow,
and it's often unreliable.
So again,
it's kind of a dramatic reminder about some of the realities of engaging in a
war in a period when even communication is complicated and difficult.
I will stop there because we are out of time.
On Thursday will be the midterm here.
Blue books will be here and ready for you and all will be okay.
I'm saying calming midterm things.
It will all be good.